new at four a report finds las vegas may  have played a big part in a rise in  covet cases across the southwest  kinsa tracks spikes and fevers using  data from its more than two  million smart thermometers the company  found out  outbreaks in southern california  coincided with a spike  here in southern nevada and people  living  in the sickest counties were twice as  likely to have traveled to the strip in  december or  early january generally  wheat fevers is a common symptom of  covid19 and we can see that  days or weeks up to up to weeks before  coven 19 cases increase and so it's a  leading indicator of where  increases are going to be  kinsa says the spread from california to  nevada is being driven by that new covid  variant  the variant from the uk was first  detected here in a test  just last week